nintendo's new president tatsumi
kimishima has vowed that the company
will continue to support the wii u
despite the consoles underperformance
and the fact that its successor the NX
could launch as early as next year in an
interview with time p Mishima
acknowledged the wii u's struggles but
said it's imperative that people who
bought the wii u feel supported and
satisfied when asked how long we you
would remain a core platform for
nintendo he said as you know within the
game business momentum is key when you
have momentum whether it's a platform or
software sales increase at this point in
the wii u lifespan we are looking at ten
million sell through for the hardware
itself which is just about a tenth of
what we sold overall for weed by
Nintendo's latest count the wii u had
sold 10.7 three million units by
comparison the original we crossed 100
million units sold more than two years
ago outpacing the xbox 360 and the ps3
kimishima went on to say nintendo has no
plans to abandon the wii u anytime soon
what I want to do what I think our first
job right now is to make sure that the
customers those ten million customers
who have a wii u at home have software
to play and we need to make sure that
they're satisfied with their purchase
and continue to enjoy playing on this
platform you can't just abandon them and
say hey it's time to move on to the next
thing upcoming wii u games from nintendo
include The Legend of Zelda Twilight
Princess HD Star Fox zero pokin
tournament and a brand new Legend of
Zelda game Nintendo does not plan to
talk in any official capacity about the
NX or whatever it ends up being called
until 2016 however kimishima has said
the platform will be dramatically
different than the wii u the NX was
first revealed in march 2015 on the same
day that nintendo announced plans to
make smartphone games the announcement
of the NX was purposefully made so
people would understand that nintendo
remains
to the console space then president
satoru iwata who passed away in July
refer to the NX as a brand new concept